All right,
let's talk about similar triangles.
Both of these triangles have
the exact same angles inside.
They're both right triangles,
which means that one of their
angles is equal to 90 degrees.
And then this top angle in triangle
B is equivalent to this
top angle in triangle A.
And this bottom angle on the right
in Triangle B Is equivalent to
this bottom right angle on triangle A.
The difference is that
the sides of this triangle
are twice as big as
the sides of this triangle.
These two triangles
are called similar triangles.
That means that the angles inside each
triangle have the same measure and
their sides are in
proportion to each other.
I can set up a proportion where I put
the side of triangle A in the numerator
and the corresponding side of
triangle B in the denominator.
So I'm comparing 2 to 4 and
I can set that equivalent to
A proportion of the other
legs of the triangles.
But this says is that the ratios
of the corresponding legs
of the similar triangles
should be equivalent.
So the ratio of 2 to 4 is the same
thing as the ratio of 3 to 6.
2/4 = 1/2.
And 3 over 6 also equals 1/2 and so we
see they are equivalent to each other.